NPR is this report some women in
non-binary drivers for Lyft can now
match up with women and non-binary
Riders using a new feature launched by
the ride share service earlier this week
the in-app option called women plus
connect was added to lift service in a
move to improve safety after a raft of
lawsuits in recent years accused the
company of failing to protect passengers
and drivers
it's also designed to boost the number
of women and non-binary drivers working
for the San Francisco based company
currently they make up to just 23
percent of the drivers on the platform
according to Lyft
this highly requested feature offers
more control over the Driving Experience
for women and non-binary people allowing
them to feel that much more confident
and with fewer barriers to driving more
women can access flexible earning
opportunities lift set of statements so
um this creates a situation where I
believe it's both driver and Rider can
match up with women or non-binary if
they so choose and I think the other
ride sharing apps have something like
this
or they will if they don't
already
now this this is funny for a few reasons
uh the first one being
like
if you're saying that women are at
special risk when they drive for these
services
then why are you trying to increase the
number of women driving
so on one hand they have this feature
because women are are at risk we're told
and
it and actually that part
I would
you know if you're doing something like
driving for a cab service a glorified
cab service
like you're it's better you're better
off being a man than a woman I think it
was a woman there's there's more danger
involved there's there's danger you're
interacting with strangers and cars so
it's danger no matter if you're a man or
a woman
um there's going to be more danger for a
woman than for a man
so I don't deny that
but if that's the case then why why is
why is your next sentence that you're
trying to bring in more women drivers
if anything you should be trying to have
less so that they're not put in danger
and then the second thing of course the
irony is that
in this effort to protect women you're
actually just putting them in more
danger you're enabling perverts
so now you can match up
with with women whether it's a driver or
a rider
you can match up and say oh I want a
woman
well clearly that that can easily be
abused like the sort of people that
you're worried about getting in the car
with a woman driver
well those people that you're worried
about the men presumably they know about
this system and so they can easily game
it by just declaring themselves on the
app to either be a woman or be
non-binary it's like literally I have to
do is just click a button I assume
that's it and so those very people that
that you know small minority of people
who would potentially be a danger to
women drivers
all you're telling them is now you could
be now you uh dangerous men you can
exclusively have women drivers picking
you up
by plugging yourself into this women
connect thing
because now if it was some way where it
was really just women actual women who
were allowed to take part in this women
connect uh program
that's one thing
but they can't
they they want to limit it to women for
the safety of women but they can't
ideologically and so it's not women
connect it's women plus connect
right so we're including non-binary
including trans uh which means that just
any man
the kind of man who again
vast majority of men are getting picked
up for a lift or an Uber and uh and
there's not gonna be any problem and
they're gonna be like me they're gonna
sit back they're not going to even say a
word except for high and you know when
they get out they're gonna say thanks
and that's gonna be the end of it
that small portion of men
who are a danger now they're saying oh
okay well this is great
now I can only be matched with women
drivers I just love to say that I'm
non-binary it's like no one can there's
no it's not like the same litmus test
here no one can tell me that I'm not
in a world filled with uncertainties one
shocking headline spreads Panic like
wildfire and grocery stores are empty
within hours so it's crucial to be ready
for whatever comes your way having a
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the assurance
that you and your loved ones will be
well taken care of right now my Patriot
Supply is giving you 25 off a
three-month emergency food kit to help
you start growing your supply go to
preparewithwalsh.com and grab this
special price before it ends your one
week emergency food kit provides over 2
000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations you can enjoy a wide variety
of my Patriot Supply food from
buttermilk pancakes and chicken alfredo
to rice pudding and their meals have you
covered for every part of your day the
best part is each meal is delicious
don't wait for disaster to strike before
taking action invest in your safety and
well-being by securing your food storage
today go to preparewithwalsh.com and
save 25 off a three-month Supply let's
prepare with walsh.com
and then that goes to the final problem
of course which is the most obvious one
uh which is that that Lyft wants to have
this program for women but of course
they cannot Define what a woman is and
so it's just it doesn't work it's
impossible it's impossible to make it
work
you can't do anything it turns out you
can't do anything for women you cannot
help women
um uh
if you cannot Define what it means which
is unfortunate
because in theory again some something
like this could make a lot of sense
uh if my if my wife was ever to take an
Uber or a lift which I very rarely has
she ever done had to do that but uh if
she did like I would prefer to have a
woman pick her up I'd you know if for
some reason I'm out of town I can't be
there to you know help uh I'd prefer to
have a woman woman pick up because I
feel safer about that
but because you can't Define a woman it
doesn't mean anything it means
absolutely nothing
as always thanks for checking out this
video if you liked listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts